ein wunderschöner Morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen Minecraft
Welt und meine lieben Freunde wir dürfen
gar nicht lange Zeit verlieren denn mir
wurde unten in die Kommentare
geschrieben luca du kannst deine
Hühnchen nicht nur weiter vermehren
indem du irgendwie die Eier von den
nimmst und das auf dem Boden Haut
ihr kriegt keinen Weizen von mir denn
ich kann die auch einfach Paaren mit den
Samen die ich gerade schon in der Hand
habe und das ist eigentlich
nee alles cool sind ja nicht irgendwie
meine Boote oder so
um diese Paarung der Hühnchen jetzt mal
zu testen würde ich sagen bewegen wir
uns mal straight darüber direkt zur
Tierinsel hier vorne und während ich
hier gerade noch ein Bildchen sitze kann
ich euch auch ganz kurz darüber
informieren dass ich ein neues Foto auf
Instagram hochgeladen habe
interessiert niemanden falls euch doch
interessiert dann schaut gerne vorbei
und lasst ein Like da bitte danke das
wäre total freundlich wo sind meine
Hühnchen hier ist eins und hier vorne
auch okay nice wir haben sie direkt
gefunden also hier rechts geht drauf
hier drauf das klappt und wir haben
einen Baby chicken n
ich kann man gerade mal ein paar
Sekunden auf der Welt sein und jetzt
schon so asozial zu mir sein wenn wir
jetzt allerdings schon mal hier sind
können wir auch mal ganz kurz unsere
anderen Tierchen hier ein bisschen
miteinander fahren hier vorne zum
Beispiel direkt die Schweinchen dann
machen wir hier kurz rechtsklick drauf
und hier dann haben wir ein neues Baby
Schweinchen am Start jetzt jeden Moment
Zack und jetzt können wir noch mal ganz
kurz das Weizen nehmen ich weiß
allerdings gerade nicht wem wir hier
miteinander fahren können wir haben dort
vorne ein Schäfchen und wir haben hier
vorne noch ein Schäfchen also kommt
immer bitte mit und du mit dem hier
einmal ganz kurz zack zack ihr beiden
könnt mal ganz kurz noch ein Kind
kriegen und wir haben hier noch eine Kuh
und wo war denn noch eine andere Kuh du
bitte einmal ganz kurz noch mal eben mit
ihm hier euch fortpflanzen dass wir auf
jeden Fall auch super dann bekommen wir
da noch eine kleine neue Baby Kuh und
die Tierinsel wird mehr und mehr zum
Leben erwacht Alter sieht das schön aus
ich bin so glücklich über unsere Welt
auch da hinten einfach mit dem
Piratenschiff
[Musik]
[Applaus]
haltet euer Maul es ist allerdings
eigentlich auch ganz gut dass wir jetzt
gerade mal kurz noch auf der Tierinsel
hier sind denn in der heutigen Episode
habe ich eine riesiges Ziel und zwar
möchte ich ja die ABH dorthin bauen
die Angel und Bootshütte
und dafür brauchen wir noch eine Menge
mehr Eichenholz
[Musik]
so ich habe dort gerade eine Menge Bäume
abgefällt ich habe jetzt locker
anderthalb Stacks mehr Eichenholz und
ich habe auch alles wieder neu bepflanzt
also dort die ganzen Setzlinge
selbstverständlich wieder hingesetzt
dementsprechend packe ich auch diese
Dinge jetzt noch mal ganz kurz hier in
die Kiste rein ich hoffe mal dass das
jetzt hier reichen sollte an Holz und
das hier packe ich auch noch mal eben
kurz rein und den Rest sortiere ich eben
und gehe dann schlafen und dann nehmen
wir uns hier am nächsten Tag wieder wenn
es losgeht mit dem Bau von der Angel und
Bootshütte die wird sehr riesig ich habe
auch ein sehr großes Ding von der Person
ein neuer Morgen erwartet uns hier in
unserer kleinen süßen Minecraft Welt
meine lieben Freunde wir sehen schon
hier hinten die Bäume fangen wieder an
zu wachsen und wir fangen nun auch
endlich an mit unserem Plan für die
heutige Episode nämlich die Angel und
Bootshütte habe ich ja gerade schon
gesagt ich habe
und guck mal ist alles wieder gewachsen
und so darum soll es heute allerdings
nicht gehen wir können hier vorne noch
mal ganz kurz den Baum hier generell so
ein bisschen kleiner machen bzw das
Laufen bisschen entfernt fällt mir
gerade so auf wir haben das ja damals
auf der einen Seite entfernt damit ich
mir nicht mehr den Kopf stoße an dem
Laub wenn ich den Weg runter laufe aber
dann haben wir so jetzt auch mal ein
bisschen Cleaner und der Baum sieht
nicht mehr nur so auf einer Seite
abgehackt aus immer das hier aber auch
noch etwas verändert zu viel
ich Idiot von daher hier wieder ein hin
aber den hier können wir auf jeden Fall
wegnehmen dann sieht das hier ein
bisschen China aus und hier müssen wir
noch ganz kurz warten bis hier der
Wegner weg so dass wir hier auch ein
Trampelpfad machen können die Sache ist
allerdings dass wir jetzt erstmal hier
vorne diese drei Stufen wegnehmen werden
denn das wird ersetzt durch die Stufen
die wir hier vorne drin haben die
eichenholzstufen die kommen hier nämlich
so schon lang die Sache ist allerdings
dass wir den Weg ja so ein bisschen
auslaufen lassen müssen von daher würde
ich den hier zwar noch wegnehmen hier
vorne dann allerdings den Weg noch
auslaufen lassen und dann hier geht's
dann los in Richtung Boot ich brauche
mal ganz kurz den Weg
[Musik]
so soll das hier vorne nämlich Aussehen
wir haben hier so Falltüren da können
wir hier auch noch mal eben eine
hinsetzen fällt mir gerade auf Zack und
dann geht das hier so ein bisschen rüber
das ist ja zwar ein bisschen blöd aus
mit der Erde aber das wird ja zu Gras
und dann geht der Weg hier vorne lang
den hier können wir auch noch mal ganz
kurz jetzt eben ausgleichen zack sieht
auf jeden Fall definitiv schöner aus als
wärt ihr jetzt auch so eine kleine
Fläche haben genauso wie ja hier vorne
vor unserem Häuschen allerdings solltet
ihr dann so runtergehen und das wird
auch noch größer nach da hinten hin
deswegen muss ja noch ein bisschen mehr
Eichenholz holen die Sache ist
allerdings dass wir jetzt hier auch
erstmal den Weg rumziehen werden und
hier noch die letzten drei rein die
Sache ist jetzt allerdings dass wir das
hier wieder abbauen werden denn hier
kommen auch Fichtenholz Falltüren hin
das wird so ein kleiner Weg hier von der
Seite rüber dementsprechend nehmen wir
die jetzt ganz kurz und platzieren die
zack zack zack und hier auch noch mal
drei Stück eins zwei und drei und jetzt
benötigen wir unsere eichenholztreppen
bzw sogar noch ein paar mehr habe ich ja
hier ziemlich viele mehr machen können
und erstmal auch noch ganz eine kurze
unten die Sachen holen wir dürfen
nämlich nicht verschwenden wir brauchen
wirklich so viel Materialien für dieses
ganze Projekt die Treppen kommen hier
nämlich so ran zack zack und hier vorne
auch wieder zack so ein bisschen wie in
unserer Strandvilla da hinten dir noch
nicht mal ansatzweise fertig ist nur
halt ein bisschen umgekehrt also hier
halt eher so dass es nicht als als
Bargeld sondern so wie in der
Strandvilla mit den quarztreppen äh wie
wir das dort gemacht haben also hier
auch noch mal Zack und zack und jetzt
kümmern wir uns ein bisschen hier vorne
um das was hier drauf stehen soll denn
hier kommt unsere fischershütte hin also
zwei davon und einen Eichenholz oben
drauf ja auch zwei und ein Eichen Holz
oben drauf hier vorne auch wieder zwei
Abstand zack zack und auch ein obendrauf
und hier vorne dann auch noch passend zu
den anderen zack zack und auch ein
obendrauf das liegt jetzt relativ
kleines kleines Häuschen aber das soll
ja auch nicht allzu riesig werden denn
wir haben da vorne ja ein Holz wir haben
hier eine Biene
was genau kann ich eigentlich mit diesem
Bienen machen oh mein Gott dieser
schön wie das da steht aber wir
konzentrieren uns ja heute auf dieses
angel- und Bootshaus aka
Ehe auf Englisch stinkt es noch
peinlicher hier vorne das Eichenholz hin
und hier eine Fichtenholz
und hier sieht schon fertig aus
aber von hier
wow
ja hier vorne ziehen wir dann das ganze
auf jeden Fall auch mit
eichenholzbrettern hoch und genau das
gleiche spiegeln wie auch hier für die
andere Seite der hier sollte nicht sein
im Baum einmal ganz kurz wieder ab und
jetzt nehmen wir unsere Eichenholz
Treppen und setzen die so und so hin und
in die Mitte eine Eichenholz Falltür das
haben wir schon öfter so gemacht dass
wir Falltüren einfach als Fenster
benutzt haben hier vorne auch und hier
vorne machen wir das ganze so mit den
Treppen genauso wie wir das hier vorne
unten gemacht haben da kommen dann zwei
einzige Mauern drauf und darüber auch
noch mal drei Eichen Holzbretter für das
Dach nehmen wir Steinziegel Treppen und
setzen die ich so so und so hin und das
gleiche auf der anderen Seite hier auch
zack zack und zack auf der Seite da
vorne wird es ein bisschen anders
gemacht doch jetzt brauchen wir erstmal
noch unsere Steinziegel Stufen denn die
setzen wir so und dann muss ich mich
einmal ganz kurz hoch bauen zack zack
da setzen wir hier oben nämlich noch
eine drauf dann baue ich mir mal ganz
kurz das hier wieder ab ich weiß ich
könnte auch meinen Gerüst nehmen was ich
mir aus dem Bambus gemacht habe
allerdings bin ich jetzt so gewohnt dass
hier mit meinen Holz bzw Erde immer zu
machen da kann ich das auch noch ein
bisschen länger machen mehr Treppen habe
ich gar nicht doch hier sind da am Start
das werden wir ziemlich auf der anderen
Seite genauso bauen allerdings ein
bisschen anders denn das wird nicht
schon hier sein sondern schon äh erst
hier wird das so anfangen hier zack eine
dran und hier vorne machen wir das
gleiche auch Zack und zack dann fängt
ziemlich schon hier vorne an mit denen
jetzt brauche ich mir ganz kurz hier auf
Treppen hoch jetzt fängt sie mich hier
schon an mit unseren Steinziegel Dings
Zack und zack und zack dann bauen wir
allerdings die hier mal eben wieder ab
und dann können wir jetzt nämlich völlig
entspannt eine Laterne hinsetzen so dass
wir hier zumindest ein bisschen
Beleuchtung haben die Sonne geht schon
wieder unter deswegen beweg ich mich mal
ganz schnell zu meinem provisorischen
Bett hier vorne und gehen eine Runde
schlafen es ist wieder eine richtige Bau
Folge heute also wenn ihr Action wollt
dann schaltet in einer der nächsten
Folgen wieder ein wo wir dann werden
schon lange keine Action mehr ich freue
mich auch ehrlich gesagt wieder so ein
bisschen auf den netter weil wir ja
immer noch eine Menge Quarz brauchen für
unsere moderne Strandhaus oder da vorne
wir konzentrieren uns nun allerdings
erstmal auf das Dach von unserem kleinen
fischershäuschen hier vorne ich muss
mich wieder hoch bauen nehme ich erstmal
mal ganz kurz mein Holz und das Dach
soll nämlich aus diesen
eichenholztreppen hier sein und hier auf
der anderen Seite auch dann müssen wir
das allerdings hier vorne das ist sehr
glaube ich nicht gut auseinander Treppe
wir müssen wir das so hinsetzen deswegen
nun erstmal ganz kurz Konzentration auf
dass sie an der Seite da setzen wir das
nämlich wieder so hin das haben wir ja
bisher bei fast jedem Dach auf unserer
Insel so gemacht dass das von unten dann
auf jeden Fall auch ganz nice aussieht
also hier zack zack und von der Seite
auch noch mal BAM und BAM dann können
wir hier in die Mitte das ganze so
setzen und dann zieht sich da drüber der
Giebel ist es der Giebel ich weiß es
nicht ich kenne mich damit nicht so gut
aus allerdings nur bis hierhin denn ab
hier haben wir dann wieder eine
Steinziegel Stufe und auch wieder die
Steinziegel Treppen die wir von der
Seite und von ihrer Seite hier so
hochziehen werden also hier auch mal
Zack und dann jetzt auch noch mal kurz
hier rüber gejumpt und hier nochmal
einen dran und hier wieder Bam Bam und
nun die letzten beiden Zack und zack
dann können wir den Rest des Daches
jetzt mit diesen Eichenholz Treppen hier
vorne machen BAM und auf der anderen
Seite ja auch noch mal eben zack zack
drei vier und fünf von unten sieht das
Ganze jetzt ein bisschen doof aus weil
das hier offen ist dafür nehmen wir ganz
einfach unsere eichenholzbretter und
setzen die hier vorne hin ich glaube die
Reichen jetzt nicht aus für das was sie
hier vorne noch brauchen genau da
brauchen wir noch ein paar mehr ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch welche in der Kiste
habe das haben wir natürlich nicht aber
ist kein Problem dann machen wir uns
hier einfach eben kurz vier neue und
nehmen die auch noch für das hier nun
müssen wir allerdings auch noch ein
bisschen Beleuchtung dran machen denn
hier vorne
hier vorne muss auf jeden Fall noch eine
Lampe dran hier benötigen wir keine das
wird unser Eingang und hier vorne
so
wir brauchen erstmal ein Geländer hier
aber noch Probleme oder habe ich ja
jemand eichenholzaun am Start also hier
einfach mal alles passend hinsetzen hier
auf der Seite auch zack das war vorhin
mein mein kleines pseudogerüst und da
hoch zu kommen hier vorne den Weg und so
und jetzt noch Zaun Tore dazwischen da
frag mich ganz viele mal Luca warum sind
da Zaun Tore das hat ja auch bei meinem
Haus hier oben gemacht um euch das mal
ganz kurz zu zeigen das ist eigentlich
auch richtig süß ne Fall so eine
Mischung irgendwie aus Modern hier oben
mit diesem Glas und hier unten mit
diesem mäßigen Look äh das hatte ich
auch gemacht ich finde das einfach ganz
schön wenn das hier nicht mit dem Boden
verbunden ist und
wir müssen das echt mehr Wertschätzung
öfter in den never gehen allerdings soll
es ja heute nicht um den never gehen
sondern um meine ABH hier vorne sieht
schon richtig nice aus finde ich ähm
jetzt müssen wir hier vorne allerdings
erstmal noch die Gelände auch ein
bisschen am Start bringen also so wieder
zack zack und hier noch einen Zaun hin
hier vorne wird's ein bisschen crazy da
benötigen wir erstmal noch unser
Fichtenholz unsere Zaun Tore hier vorne
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich die jetzt
genau hinsetze ob ich die so hinsetzen
ich glaube ich setze die andersrum hin
also quasi an die Teile hier dran dann
haben wir einen kleinen Unterschied zu
dem Weg hier vorne der herunterführt so
und so und genau das gleiche mache ich
jetzt hier vorne auch mal Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam mich erinnert das hier vorne
immer so ein bisschen wenn ich hier so
runter gucke an so äh Malediven Urlaub
also ich war noch nie auf den Malediven
[Musik]
aber alles was man in den Stories von
influencern und Bloggern und so man
sieht die dort am Start sind da ist das
so ganz ganz flaches Wasser aber dann
trotzdem darüber gebaut so mit Holz und
so ist eigentlich ganz nice wo ist die
andere Fichtenholz Falltür ich glaube
die haben wir gerade schon aufgenommen
wir müssen auf jeden Fall hier auch noch
Zäune draufsetzen allerdings kommt hier
noch mehr dran also ihr seht auch schon
hier vorne ist eine Treppe das wird noch
ein bisschen größer wir bauen hier noch
so ein Fischers Kran hin ich weiß nicht
ob das Sinn ergibt aber ihr seht auf
jeden Fall nachher was ich meine und
dafür müssen wir auch diese beiden hier
noch mal eben abbauen Zack und zack die
andere ist hier runter geflogen nämlich
auch noch mal ganz kurz mit jetzt muss
ich hier von der Seite wieder hoch es
ist gerade ein bisschen stressig es ist
allerdings ja auch eine baufolge und mir
gefallen diese baufolge ehrlich gesagt
auch mal ganz gut von daher hier vorne
erstmal drauf konzentrieren dann machen
wir das nämlich so zack zack zack und
zack und hier vorne machen wir das ganze
auch einfach so so und so dann haben wir
auf jeden Fall das Geländer hier schon
mal fertig jetzt nehmen wir uns
allerdings noch mal ganz kurz den
eichenzaun und setzen den hierhin so
dass er so ein in das Dach trägt also
braucht man natürlich nicht in Minecraft
generelle Statik in Minecraft
minenproblem aus Verwendung Sand und
Kies geht äh da kannst du wirklich
einfach so offen auf so einem sandturm
kannst du den hoch bauen und dann
einfach da drüber so riesig viel
Bruchstein setzen ist aber auch egal
hier soll es heute nicht um Physik gehen
denn ihr seht schon ich sortiere mich
hier gerade wieder ein bisschen den nun
benötige ich mein komplettes Eichenholz
und wir werden dann hier muss auch noch
irgendwas hin ne
können wir irgendwie noch Erde hinsetzen
oder so habe ich die gerade hier ja habe
ich sogar am Start kann man ganz kurz
mal eben hierhin packen dann wird das
auch noch zu krass ich benötige meine
ganzen Eichenstämme und dann können wir
mal gucken ob das was wird eventuell mit
den ganzen Sachen die ich hier habe ich
muss auf jeden Fall auch noch mir ein
paar mehr hiervon machen sieben Stück
sollten reichen und jetzt euch erstmal
eine ganz kurze timeless wie ich hier
noch ein paar Pfeile hochziehen aus dem
Ozean
[Musik]
so das hier haben wir auf jeden Fall
fertig die Sache ist allerdings dass ich
nur noch zwei Holz unten habe das seht
ihr ja schon in meinem Inventar und das
reicht auf gar keinen Fall also die
Stelzen hier habe ich jetzt wirklich von
unten bis oben hochgezogen ihr wisst ja
ich möchte dass es hier alles zusammen
passt ich weiß dass das auch laufen
würde wenn ich die einfach nur ab hier
hoch Bau allerdings hat mich wirklich
bei der Zauberinsel also hier hinter
wirklich total getriggert auf Dauer dass
die Teile nicht richtig mit dem bunten
Boden verbunden waren ich weiß ich habe
auch den Kommentar gelesen das ist bei
bei meiner Villager Insel auch nicht so
richtig Sinn macht weil die komplette
Insel irgendwie
schwimmt da irgendwie komplett rum
[Musik]
das Schaf stand einfach hier und genau
in dem Moment wo der Baum gewachsen ist
ist es da drin gestorben ich würde sagen
ich gehe erstmal ganz kurz schlafen und
setze hier meinen Reisebett hin und wenn
das der Bürgermeister war Alter dann
haben wir aber ein riesiges Problem dann
müssen wir einen neuen Bürgermeister
bestimmen wir haben ja eh nur drei
Schafe auf dieser Insel das hier ist
nicht der Bürgermeister wir haben noch
eine fifty fifty Chance
[Musik]
ich glaube wir brauchen langsam echt
eine grabinsel ich weiß jetzt nicht wer
hier vorhin alles gestorben ist
allerdings waren es ja wirklich
verschiedene Fleischsorten also es war
ja einmal rohes Hammelfleisch es war
rohes Schweinefleisch und Rindfleisch
das hatte ich alles glaube ich vorher
noch nicht im Inventar also es sind auf
jeden Fall einige Tiere gestorben ich
kann die nicht mehr hinten auf meinen
Grabstein schreiben das schwitzt echt
geil aus voller traurige Thema ja
eigentlich gerade ich kann die nicht
mehr auf meinen Grabstein schreiben
Freunde der ist schon voll das Schild da
vorne deswegen ich habe jetzt auch gar
kein Weizen hier dabei ich kann jetzt
jemanden Paaren hier gerade außer die
Schweine also jetzt machen wir
irgendwann nachher auf jeden Fall der
Bürgermeister lebt auf jeden Fall noch
und jetzt euch die ganz kurze time
natürlich das Holz hier zusammen suche
[Musik]
so ich habe eineinhalb Stacks neue
Eichenstämme und im Inventar seht ihr
schon ich habe auch die ganzen Bäume
selbstverständlich wieder neu
angepflanzt und wir fahren direkt zurück
hier vorne zu unserer ABH zu unserer
Angel und Bootshütte meine lieben
Freunde nun geht's nämlich direkt weiter
hier vorne mit dem Bereich wo wir angeln
werden dafür brauchen wir eine Menge
fichtenholzfaltung ist auf jeden Fall
deutlich zu wenig ich hoffe mal ich habe
mir noch ein paar mehr gemacht hier
vorne ich habe was
ich
[Musik]
habe leider keinen Knochenmehl mehr am
Start deswegen müssen wir jetzt leider
mit den fichtenholzeln auskommen die ich
mir gerade mit unserem Fichtenholz
machen konnte das sind nämlich nur 25
Stück die Sache ist allerdings das ein
paar Bäume gewachsen sind und zwar haben
wir hier ein bienennester am Start wir
haben hier plötzlich ein bienennester am
Start und wir haben hier erstmal noch
ein Setzling wir haben hier vorne noch
ein Bienennest am Start und sogar hier
vorne noch irgendwo eins glaube ich
nicht ich glaube das war's wir haben
einfach drei neue bienennetze hier
plötzlich auf der Insel also besser als
eigentlich nicht laufen können und jetzt
fliegen ja auch überall so ein paar
Bienchen rum hier vorne ist noch eben
gerade eine kleine Fichte gewachsen die
können wir noch mal eben kurz mitnehmen
doch dann müssen wir das leider mit den
Fichtenholz Falltüren irgendwann später
heute erst in der Folge machen das
wollte ich eigentlich jetzt direkt
machen das ist nämlich unser Weg und das
macht halt Sinn das direkt zu machen
allerdings habe ich kein keine Knochen
mehr und muss dementsprechend noch
endlich demnächst mal wieder in den
Nether also ganz kurz wieder ins
Brötchen rein zack weg von unserer
Tierinsel und zurück zu unserer Insel es
sieht auf jeden Fall schon heiß aus hier
vorne mit der ABH die Sache ist
allerdings dass das ganze hier wirklich
noch ein deutliches Stück größer wird
also ich packe mein Brötchen erstmal
hier vorne denn hier sollen die auch
demnächst stehen einmal kurz
ausgestiegen und wir nehmen unsere
Fichtenholz Falltüren und setzen die
jetzt hier vorne so dran und jetzt
ziehen wir das hier vorne rüber wir
haben halt leider nur 22 Stück ich
glaube wir brauchen noch easy für das
komplette Projekt hier im 20 Stück mehr
oder so allerdings kann man sich das
ganze ja so glaube ich erstmal grob
vorstellen also der Weg soll halt hier
runter gehen und dann weiter bis hier
vorne hin dann können wir uns hier mal
hinstellen und Angeln hier vorne kommt
auch noch eine Kiste hin da haben wir
dann unsere ganzen Angeln und so drin
und dann geht hier vorne auch die Sonne
unter und wir können dann immer so ein
bisschen rüber gucken zu unserer
Tierinsel da sind auch gerade da vorne
ist eine neue Fichte gewachsen und hier
vorne geht der Weg halt zur Seite rüber
denn hier
so eine Bildchen anlegen
wir brauchen erstmal ein bisschen
Beleuchtung hier am Start von daher
nehmen wir hier einfach unsere
Steinziegel Mauern setzen die hier hin
hier einfach dann so Laternchen drauf
hier nehmen wir beispielsweise mal
wieder eine Steinziegel Stufe dann hier
wieder eine Steinziegel Mauer und hier
vorne auch eine Steinziegel Mauer dann
können wir hier wieder eine Steinziegel
Stufe nehmen das kann ich auch erstmal
ganz kurz hier wieder Abfällen das war
nur damit ich ganz kurz auf dieses Dach
da oben drauf komme und hier vorne zack
dann können wir hier vorne hier können
wir theoretisch ein bisschen was
verspielteres machen indem wir einfach
eine Steinziegel Mauer nehmen und dann
hier den Zaun drauf dann müssen wir uns
ja allerdings ganz kurz wieder hoch
bauen an der Seite zack zack zack diese
ich habe zwei Sand dahin gesetzt okay
hier eine Sound noch eben drauf nee hier
drauf und dann hier dran und hier vorne
an die Seite auch könnt euch
wahrscheinlich schon erahnen was ich
damit darstellen möchte und zwar eine
kleine Laterne dafür allerdings erstmal
den Sand hier vorne wegnehmen Zack und
zack und zack und dann hier auch eine
Laterne dran und hier auch doch jetzt
konzentrieren wir uns erstmal auf diesen
Bereich hier vorne wo unser kleiner
fischkran dann hochkommen soll dafür
müssen wir allerdings diese Seetang
Kacke hier erstmal kurz abfallen zack
hier ein eben kurz Hochziehen der soll
einmal so sein bitte und dann hier noch
mal eins zwei drei zur Seite rüber und
hier das auch noch mal eben kurz
Abfällen und hochziehen äh ihr merkt
schon wieder die ganze Zeit ich guck
nach rechts rüber das sieht nämlich
daran dass ich mich hier wieder
inspirieren lasse von einem Video was
ich auf Youtube gefunden habe da vorne
ist ein Zombie den töte ich mal ganz
kurz hier findet selbstverständlich
wieder einen Link dazu unten in der Info
Beschreibung also wenn ihr das ganze
nachbauen wollt dann könnt ihr das
entweder hier mit meinem Video machen
oder einfach dort mit dem Video und der
Erklärung jetzt Goldbarren kann ich
gerade nicht mitnehmen ich benötige
allerdings das forderte Fleisch ja auch
nicht also den Goldbarren nämlich gern
hier vorne noch mal eben kurz einen
drauf gesetzt hier vorne Zack und dann
hier noch mal drei rüber eins zwei drei
und dann hier auch noch mal eben
hochziehen das war's dann auch schon
tatsächlich was mit dem ganzen Holz hier
machen mussten die Sache ist dass ich
jetzt noch ganz viel davon habe ich
wünschte ich könnte daraus jetzt auch
hier irgendwelche Fichtenholz Sachen
machen allerdings funktioniert das nicht
und wir müssen demnächst wirklich noch
mal rüber da sind allerdings schon
wieder ein paar mehr Fichten gewachsen
also mache ich das mal eben direkt
[Musik]
64 Fichtenholz Falltüren konnte ich mir
jetzt tatsächlich machen mit den ganzen
Fichten die wir da vorne noch neu
gepflanzt hatten und wir haben sogar ein
neues Bienennest noch am Start also wer
mittlerweile vier Stück hinten auf der
Tierinsel was wirklich extrem krass ist
also ich habe die ganze Zeit gewünscht
ein bienennester vorne zu haben habe
schon gedacht wo ich das irgendwann
demnächst abbauen kann eventuell bzw wo
ich noch eins gefunden habe allerdings
ist das Problem jetzt gelöst wir müssen
jetzt die anderen Tiere da irgendwie so
ein bisschen Paaren demnächst und dann
haben wir auch das fertig hier vorne das
ganze auch noch mal kurz rüber ziehen
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack die Sonne geht schon wieder unter
das heißt ich gehe kurz schlafen so ein
neuer Morgen erwartet uns hier in
unserer Minecraft Welt und wir können
die Gelegenheit auch mal ganz kurz
nutzen um unseren Eichen Setzling den
ich gerade mir noch mitgenommen habe
hier vorne mal wieder hinzusetzen so
dass hier dann hoffentlich der Baum
demnächst wieder hoch wächst bzw ich
glaube ich setze ihn nicht dorthin ich
setze ihn hier hin und jetzt kümmern wir
uns endlich um die finalen Züge unserer
Angelsituation hier vorne denn wir
benötigen erstmal noch Eichenholz
Treppen und Eichenholz Stufen Elfen auf
jeden Fall zu wenig ich weiß nicht ob
ich davon noch mehr habe nee natürlich
nicht ich habe allerdings eine Menge
Holz am Start also sollte ich denke ich
hoffe ich mal kein Problem sein hier
vorne erstmal ein bisschen hoch bauen
denn wir bekommen hier die Treppen hin
so dass wir dann hier runter können das
ganze bauen wir natürlich allerdings
selbstverständlich wieder ab weil wir
auch das Holz benötigen und hier kommen
jetzt so die die untere Plattform hin wo
dann der Kran drauf kommt mit unserem
Fischer Netz
man kann zwar kein richtiges Netz in
Minecraft bauen aber ihr seht gleich was
ich meine zack zack zack und zack und
jetzt hier in die Mitte einfach eins
zwei drei vier fünf hoch und dann 1 2 3
4 zur Seite denn das hier wird unserer
Kran sein und an dem Krane runter packen
wir nun einen eichenholzzaun dann unsere
beiden Ketten die ich ja glaube ich mir
gemacht habe und hier vorne nur gerade
in der Kiste vergessen habe genau diese
beiden Ketten benötigen wir und die
Eichenholz Falltüren die sechs Stück die
ich auch hier am Start habe das hier
soll nämlich so ein bisschen unser
Fischernetz darstellen also erstmal hier
unten die Kette dran und hier auch noch
eine Kette dran da kommt dann hier eine
Eichenholz Falltür dran und an die
eichenholzfalltür kommen 1 2 3 und von
der anderen Seite die vierte die wir nun
allerdings alle einklappen und dann von
unten noch mal eine falsche da dran so
dass das hier
ein bisschen
ein Fischernetz müssen den Kran auf
jeden Fall noch ein bisschen schöner
bauen zum Beispiel können wir hier
hinten das einfach mal so machen hier
dann eine Treppe dran und dann hier
runter zack zack zack zack zack dann
haben wir hier nämlich so eine Art
Gewicht was an den Kran hier vorne trägt
mit den ganzen Fischen da müssen wir
aber schon eine Menge Fische Prinz sein
und hier bauen wir das ganze jetzt
einfach mal so und hier oben auch noch
eine dran und da drunter eine Treppe und
auf der anderen Seite genau das gleiche
also zack zack und hier auch noch mal
jetzt muss ich mich ganz kurz wieder
hoch bauen ich glaube es wäre echt gut
wenn ich mich mal mit diesem Gerüst
auseinandersetzen würde dann würden wir
eine Menge Zeit und Ressourcen immer
sparen allerdings bauen wir jetzt hier
erstmal das ganze so und zack hier vorne
das wieder abbauen und einen davon neu
hinsetzen dann haben wir nämlich hier so
ein bisschen das äh den den Kran oben
bzw den führerhäuschen keine Ahnung ob
man sowas hat bei einem Schiff
wahrscheinlich ist das alles irgendwie
automatisch gesteuert das ist mir jetzt
auch beim Hamburger Hafen aufgefallen
ich war letztens der ist ja alles mit
Computer das interessiert gerade aktuell
wahrscheinlich niemanden jetzt nehmen
wir allerdings unsere
fichtenholzfalltüren und setzen die hier
hin und hierhin und dann auch noch mal
hier und hier dann können wir die hier
so drumklappen und das gleiche hier auf
der anderen Seite auch bzw da oben soll
auch noch eine drauf das heißt dann ganz
kurz hier hoch Zack und hier mal kurz
wieder runter bauen oh mein Gott da
komplett ist so eine Biene hier an äh
das nehme ich auch mal ganz kurz weg
denn hier setze ich glaube ich noch so
eine Treppe dran dann sieht das auf der
Seite auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
schöner aus und hier dann auch noch eine
eichenholzstufe und auf der anderen
Seite machen wir das ganze
selbstverständlich auch denn da packen
wir nun auch hier oben mal eine drauf
hier eine und dann hier Zack und hier
drunter packen wir auch noch einer dann
können wir das ja auch schon wieder
abbauen und das war's dann auch schon
hier von unserer kransituation da
braucht man allerdings auch noch ein
bisschen Licht und dann gehen wir wieder
mit unserer Steinmauer so ein bisschen
vor wir brauchen generell noch ein
bisschen mehr Licht ich glaube auch ich
mache das da oben noch mal eben kurz ein
bisschen schöner äh da könnte ich mir
theoretisch mal eben kurz eine
Fichtenholz Stufe machen sofern ich noch
genug davon haben sollte ja perfekt zack
z so das Holz brauche ich gleich noch
mal ganz kurz und damit muss ich mich
hier wieder so dumm hoch bauen nämlich
Bam Bam und BAM dann können wir das
ganze hier so so und so anordnen dann
haben wir so ein kleines dechline mehr
oder weniger für unsere Laterne und wir
müssen hier vorne nun auch noch ein
bisschen ähm Beleuchtung anstatt kriegen
das mache ich nämlich hier einfach mal
bei unserem Steg BAM und BAM und dann
backen wir hier noch beispielsweise eine
Laterne hin Zack und jetzt fehlen uns
Laternen so jetzt sollte es wirklich
Reichen mit den Laternen ich nehme
trotzdem die hier noch mal eben kurz
runter ich fand gerade dass das nicht so
schön aussah dann können wir hier vorne
nämlich noch eine draufsetzen BAM dann
haben wir hier alles so mit den
Steinziegel Stufen voll das sieht auf
jeden Fall ganz cool aus und hier vorne
können wir dann auch einfach hier und
hier da fehlt mir jetzt wieder einer
aber dann mache ich das mal eben kurz
hier so nee keine Fackel sondern eine
Laterne noch mal ganz kurz eine
Steinziegel Stufe machen dann haben wir
das ganze mit den äh mit der Belichtung
nämlich jetzt auch fertig hier vorne
habe ich so das heißt Bam Bam Bam
zack die Laternen kann ich wieder
reinpacken dass das und das das brauche
ich alles nicht mehr und die Steinziegel
Stufe mal ganz kurz hier noch drauf denn
wir haben wirklich ein Großteil schon
fertig also hier unten kommt gar nicht
mehr so viel hin das einzige was jetzt
noch kommt sind Kisten und Truhen
überall verteilt da können wir nämlich
beispielsweise einfach mal hier noch ein
Fass hinstellen dann können wir hier
noch eins hinstellen dann setzen wir
hier eine Kiste hin dann setzen wir hier
eine Kiste hin das soll wirklich
aussehen wie so ein Schiffe überall
alles voll steht dann habe ich auch
schon gesagt dass ich hier auf jeden
Fall noch eine Kiste hinsetzen möchte da
müssen wir nun allerdings diese hier
ganz kurz abbauen und einen tiefer
setzen so dass wir das hier hinkriegen
dann möchte ich auch hier vorne das
können wir hier beispielsweise mal
machen zack möchte ich auch noch eine
hinsetzen aber wie mache ich das jetzt
das Ding hier wieder
abbauen eben kurz
unter Wasser ist alles immer ein
bisschen schwierig die allerdings auf
jeden Fall auch noch ein fast drauf wir
können hier auch noch eine Steinziegel
Stufe draufsetzen fällt mir gerade noch
eben auf das sei glaube ich auch ganz
cool aus und davon haben wir ja auch
noch hier vorne ein paar drin also die
auch noch mal eben kurz mitnehmen dann
können wir halt hier vorne die Boote
immer so ein bisschen parken zack also
dass sie dann natürlich hier hin und
dann noch hier vorne eins hin ich crafte
mir noch mal ganz kurz irgendwie so ein
fichtenholzboden hallo Biene dann sieht
das auf jeden Fall auch noch ein
bisschen cooler aus dafür benötigen 1 2
3 4 5 und dann einfach eben kurz alles
zu einem U anordnen dann haben wir auf
jeden Fall zwei verschiedene Boote hier
vorne am Start und schaut euch mal an
wie geil das aussieht und wenn wir dann
dem nächsten Angel haben und hier so
stehen und angeln
wie geil wäre das wir dürfen uns
allerdings nicht ablenken dass meine
lieben Freunde denn hier vorne im
Häuschen soll auch ein Bettchen sein
denn es sollen hier auf jeden Fall auch
Villager hinkommen dürfen die dann hier
irgendwie schlafen und sich dann denken
ja kommen dann werde ich mal hier
irgendwie weil sie nicht was Fischer
wahrscheinlich weil ich noch besser
rumstehen sieht schon cool aus
geil wie sich unsere ganze Insel hier
entwickelt ich werde hier vorne jetzt
einfach mal eben Fackeln anbringen bzw
haben wir auch noch eine Laterne hier
vorne drin wenn ich mich jetzt nicht
ganz irre wir von vorhin übrig hatten
genau dann haben wir da drin auf jeden
Fall noch ein bisschen mehr Licht und
wir legen uns auch direkt mal hier drin
schlafen denn dann haben wir guck mal
wieder Einstiegspunkt gesetzt habe wird
aber einfach zwei Stunden die Folge
wieder so verdammt lang nun allerdings
weiter Konzentration auf unsere ganze
kistensituation hier vorne denn ich
möchte hier zack zack das eben so
hinsetzen die ist
mein Gott ich dachte die war ein Creeper
gewesen aber war nicht die hier drunter
können wir auf jeden Fall kurz abbauen
und dann setzen wir hier noch mal ganz
kurz ein Fässchen so hin und hier vorne
soll auch noch eine Kiste hinkommen das
ist hier ein bisschen einfacher denn wir
können das hier direkt an den Rand so
platzieren dies auf jeden Fall falsch
spaziert worden von mir perfekt dann
muss ich es glaube ich doch ein bisschen
komplizierter machen und wieder hier
eine drunter setzen allerdings auch
nicht weiter schlimm Zack und zack
einmal kurz hier an der Seite hoch jetzt
können wir hier auf jeden Fall eine
Kiste kurz hin platzieren und wir können
auch diese falltürme eben ganz kurz
wieder abbauen so dann haben wir hier
auf jeden Fall die kistensituation
erstmal fertig hier soll allerdings auch
noch ein bisschen was hin nämlich hier
einmal einen Fass und hier vorne auch
und hier dann packen wir noch ein Fass
drauf und hier noch eine Kiste dann
machen wir hier noch eine Kiste hin dann
machen wir hier noch eine Kiste hin bzw
könnten wir hier auch ein Fasten machen
dann wäre es allerdings verbunden mit
dem Ding hier vorne und dann packen wir
das fast einfach mal hier vorne hin es
soll wirklich komplett so aussehen als
wenn überall hier das so Fischer mäßig
Kisten und Fässer rumstehen und dann
packen wir nun auch letzte Truhe hier
vorne hin denn jetzt sind wir
tatsächlich fertig mit unserer ABH hier
vorne ich packe das Brot hier noch mal
eben so ein bisschen schöner in der
Parkbucht Zack und jetzt kann ich euch
das ganze auch noch mal kurz zeigen also
hier vorne sollen dann so
Angelutensilien reinkommen wie
beispielsweise angeln
da gibt's ja nicht und dann können wir
uns hier hinstellen und können Sie
entspannt ein bisschen Angeln wenn wir
uns dann umdrehen sehen wir allerdings
Mensch hier sind dann auch die ganzen
Gebäude wir haben hier vorne unsere
Boote am Start falls wir rüber wollen
hinten zu Tierinsel wir haben dann hier
vorne so ein Kran am Start und hier
können wir dann die ganzen Fische lagern
denn hier ist ja auch das Fischers Netz
also das soll das so ein bisschen
darstellen und hoffentlich haben wir
dann auch ein Villager der hier für uns
ein bisschen angelt ich weiß gar nicht
ob das so genau möglich ist ich hoffe
allerdings schon also schreibst du gerne
unten in die Kommentare hier vorne mit
unserem kleinen Rundgang um das Fischers
Gebäude drumherum hier vorne kann man
dann reingehen der Fischer kann
rausgucken kann mir beim Angeln zugucken
oder kann hier schlafen gehen er hat
Beleuchtung er hat Kisten am Start um
die Sachen zu lagern und hier ist dann
der perfekte Übergang zu unserem Weg
hier vorne und zu unserer Insel ich
finde es sehr sehr sehr sehr geil das
geile ist auch wenn man dann von hier so
hochkommen und hier lang läuft sieht man
hier hinten unsere eigentliche
Startinsel unsere Spawn Insel und hier
vorne soll demnächst endlich mal der
Leuchtturm hinkommen da freue ich mich
auch schon extrem drauf wenn man dann
hier hoch geht und man sieht hier hinten
von so einem Leuchtturm begrüßt hier ist
das Schwert dann unten ist die
Zauberinsel passiert alles so unfassbar
gerade auf dieser Insel ich bin mega
stolz auf dieses ganze Projekt hier
meine lieben Freunde von daher bin ich
an der Stelle das heute wieder jetzt
auch beenden wenn
es Euch wissen wollt wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder in einer neuen Episode
Minecraft mit Luca 20 und ihr könnt ja
schon mal in die Kommentare schreiben
was ich dort machen soll tschüssi
[Musik]